once a week they meet here after school
to discuss the next steps
protesting collecting donations the
students of the private waldorf school
and cut bows say they can't accept that
their afghan schoolmates are going to be
told to leave Germany Amana said so fans
and if you see it on TV they're just
getting deported but if you know these
people then it gets totally personal it
affects you and you start obsessing
about it Afghanistan Pakistan is a
country where there's always terror and
attacks and kidnappings every day it
just isn't safe you can't deport someone
to that place the Afghans have been in
school here for a year they study
together with German students and spend
their free time with each other
wali Youssef syv was the first to
receive his deportation order in 2015 he
fled the Taliban they had tried to
recruit him in Kunduz asana shovels if
you're not being threatened with
deportation you can't imagine what we're
going through
I can't sleep alone at night I'm always
scared they're coming to get me when
asylum applications are denied the
city's foreigners registration office
has to organize and carry out the
deportation there are no exceptions
in the United States in individual cases
it's regrettable what is happening we
need to framework for everything for the
actions we have to take it may seem
heartless sometimes but that's the way
it is is we have to act according to
this framework and ultimately we need to
treat all people equally but the
students reject that reasoning they've
solicited donations from a variety of
sources
so far they've collected nearly two
thousand euros to pay lawyers to defend
the Afghans against deportation they've
also set up a petition and have already
gathered some 70,000 signatures
most of them online but not everyone
agrees Cooke bus is also home to plenty
of people with anti-refugee sentiments
the students only go out in groups less
detective economic violence the fact
that they still out petitions is the
least
there are also fistfights that we don't
need and that put us in danger too
that's the way it is it's enough to get
pepper sprayed in the eyes then you have
to go to the doctor I might yeah Alden
it's mono muscle has misdiagnosed a farm
garden delamere Campbell oh my heart
swells when I see how some people help
me and my friends they stick by me and
do everything they can so that I don't
have to go back to Afghanistan
they love us and we love them equally de
walle
especially loves playing soccer with the
group he dreams of meeting Manuel Neuer
from the German national team and his
schoolmates are doing everything they
can so he can stay in Germany long
enough to make his dream come true are
you